[Music]  i'm geraldo rivera and i have been at  fox news for 20 years  i remember when fox news started in the  basement  right in this building and everybody  said no chance no chance at all it will  be a fringe product for a slice of the  american people gerald rivera fox news  they took all of these people from all  these different walks of life put them  together and allowed them to be  themselves that's what is unique the  bosses said do your thing get out there  report get as close to the action as you  possibly can and then you take it away  we trust you this has been politicized  nobody here has censored me nobody here  has told me what to say my point of view  is often at odds with many people in  this building still they let me say it  this is  the embodiment of the first amendment  and good journalism and service to you